outright
everybody looked great everybody had
such a great attitude the facility was
really clean and just so much more
advanced
technology can truly enhance your
education
when we brought in chromebooks and we
started using the smart tvs we really
tapped into the 21st century learner
being a student of paul mitchell is
great because the learning leaders are
there to guide you in the right
direction they give you the opportunity
to make decisions on your own they
accept you for who you are and they're
always welcome and honest and open
we have encouraged our guests to host
google reviews so far to date have over
100 reviews with an average rating of
4.5 stars
i like that this isn't just
for hair and beauty but it's also a
business college
you can learn hair you can brush it you
can tease that you can learn all of that
but to do business that's something that
really takes a whole different level of
education
whether we're in the classroom or at the
color bar we're always having a great
time at paul mitchell the school of st
louis
being a student paul mitchell gives you
a lot of opportunity for when you're
ready to get out into the real world
thank you for taking a sneak peek of our
campus and we can't wait for you to come
and see what a paul mitchell education
can do for you
hello everybody we're back uh your host
chess grandmaster yasuo sarawan along
with my friend and colleague
ben feingold
welcome again ben
sorry that jennifer shahadi what isn't
here
allergy sufferer i'm afraid and sorry
for that technical problem we are having
a wonderful interview with the founder
rexingfield which we will show you
shortly and in the meanwhile as we're
getting that one teed up uh ben you had
a pretty sharp game that was going on
between josh friedl
and mack mullner
and things are definitely heated up in
that game yeah let's go back a few moves
to when knight takes e2 was played
this was the navara game you were
talking about yes exactly and mullner
played h6 kicking the knight back to
somewhere safer right knight to f3
and knight to a6 black completes
development but sort of on the side of
the board and this was the one marie
said what i tell my students don't do
that don't put your knight on the edge
boy whenever we have these strong events
the u.s championship the us women's
championship i'm always like how do i
explain these moves to my students
the rules are being violated all right
and what happened e3 okay
queen d6 also very self-explanatory
white castles mm-hmm and i think we both
like white center definitely pretty nice
for a grundfeld type position we love
the classical center
rook c8 preparing to play c5 all right
knight to f4 hmm
interesting move i would have brought
the rooks into the center yeah
maybe white wants to play e5 e6 or e5
and knight takes g6 and do something
mean yes because there is a well there's
sort of a nice pin here on the f7 pawn
and
g6 can be a little loose that's a very
aggressive move knight to f4
king h7 breaking the pin
and side stepping two t3
interesting maneuver controlling two key
center squares
wow knight f4 to d3 don't see that in
the grunfeld very often no you don't
and f5
taking advantage of white's maneuvering
and keeping the rooks not in the center
right black immediately attacks on the
king's side
f5 is always a really double-edged move
in the grenfell sometimes i'm happy my
opponent plays it and sometimes i'm not
so happy exactly so it's always very
scary
that's a key strategic moment right
there ben when he plays the move e4
takes f5
lots of ramifications
one of the things that happens in the
groomfeld why you don't really like this
kind of a counter-attacking move in the
center is because of the move e4 e5
which closes out the bishop on g7
at the cost of the d5 square but in
either case whether you play e4 takes f5
or e4 e5
black still gets the d5 square and the
move e4 e5
grabbing space would have
attracted me yeah we're actually trying
to i mean
black's trying to get rid of the white
center here with the e4 and d4 pawns
from the side pawn activate the rook
and yeah usually white's playing e5 and
black is trying to get the white squares
at the center but here i think because
both of white knights can go to e5
he was attracted on not playing e5 and
hopefully putting one of his knights
there later fair enough
and well mac is thinking about which way
to recapture he must have recaptured
while we were analyzing the game
so
let's have a look at the current
position i think he would probably play
rook takes f5 that would be my guess
rook takes f5 sets up an idea of perhaps
sacrificing the exchange
on f3 in the near future and we do have
those moves rook takes f5 knight c5
putting pressure on e6 and well
immediately threatening knight takes b7
as well as these this offside knight on
a6
now i mean the move that
what all soviets
school
children
uh learn is that in such positions
the
move that you want to analyze is rook
takes f3
messing up the kingside pawn structure
now here it's doubtful that there's
enough compensation for the exchange
but with black's king a little bit
exposed it it
does throw the game
into a bit of a spin
rook f8 again i don't believe that the
uh compensation is going to be worth an
exchange but it's the move that you have
to look at i hate to agree with you but
i agree with you you do no no i love you
when is our tiebreaker uh maurice
yesterday and i have sort of a similar
style except that he plays well that's
the only difference otherwise it's
almost the same um yeah you always have
to watch out for rook takes f3 but i
agree here i don't think white's as
worried as in some positions and we see
this idea in a lot of different openings
not just this one
and while it seems like if black doesn't
have this exchange sacrifice and just
tries to quote play chess i sort of like
white in this position big time big time
that b7 square you pointed out the e6
square
but our co-leader
um
alex linderman is doing wonderful things
as black in round three and maurice is
going to show you exactly how and why
well we might end up calling him our
soul leader after this round is up
because it seems as though he has the
primrose path laid out for him now the
computer is saying make just about any
good move and you're winning
why is that because after the move
bishop f5 move rook f1 was played and
then f6 and now the only fighting chance
was to play the move h3 fighting in
quotes black was still better but not
yet by too much but instead in time
trouble the move bishop to d2 was played
this move the computer just says no
you're dead and in fact multiple ways to
die one way we discuss and it thinks is
probably the primary candidate move is
the move queen to c6 now aggressing this
knight another move is h4 but look at
this knight nowhere to go nothing to do
with it there are different moves you
could play to defend the one i've been
analyzing mainly is this one rook over
to e1 but this explosive move comes in
h4 a real bone cruncher all of black
pieces are primed and ready to attack
this king the only one not working now
is this rook feeling a little bit sad
that all the other pieces are having so
much fun you look at this position
there's just nothing to do everything
here is hopeless the move h3 trying to
chase tonight now well by now you
guessed it wonk a night sacrifice
everything is hanging here if you drop
back and take with the knight then
simply h takes g3 and this knight cannot
move because of that nasty pin on the
long diagonal and this is just going to
be all she wrote folks bishop to e3
doesn't help trying to blunt that force
of that diagonal after this trade rook
takes and that mate threat
with the queen with the rook also a
lateral threat on the bishop somebody's
gonna drop a piece is going to fall off
the board so here after this move bishop
to d2 black has a choice like i said
queen c6 or h4 probably still in his
preparation imagine such a beautiful
miniature to win as black let's go to
see what he actually did in the game
which move he chose after bishop to d2
let's get back to the game
here it is still lenderman on move he
simply has to find this move pull the
game back up again he simply has to find
either queen c6 h4 also wins rook 88
wins all of the moves win it's crazy to
have such an advantageous position but
sometimes there's an embarrassment of
riches in chess you see all these moves
and you figure
do they all can i really just win with
everything is that true and you start
looking for the fine point the right one
and then you make a mistake there he's
played the third choice rook 88 the
third choice of houdini still trust me
still devastating still winning but very
classic very human choice to bring the
rook into the game to say look
i've been trained to use all my pieces
and there goes that sixth piece in the
attack and white with just all targets
to worry about right here all of this is
targets the knight's a target the
bishop's a target that bishop's a target
this pawn is a target this pawn will
become one too the king's a target
everywhere it's target practice
back to you guys
thank you maurice and as my trainer
international master
um
nikolai minev would say
full
a disaster
disaster on the chessboard when maurice
was having this discussion of the game
this move wins this because this was i
was thinking of our good friend roman
ginger hashfield who's played in many
u.s championships he would look at a
position like this and say
i am looking but i cannot find a move
that doesn't win
wow and sometimes as you as maurice was
mentioning there's an embarrassment of
riches i am one of those players i like
to see one clear clean win and i go for
it and in this position unfortunately
for lenderman he just had so many just
nice choices he wants to play queen c6
rook d8 h4 but every single natural move
i think the computer now
is giving a plus four
pawn advantage to lenderman and uh with
good reason i actually thought it was
higher than 0.88 a moment ago
but it's very nice that lenderman played
rook again it's very morphy-esque
lecture about morphine i make videos
about morphe i talk about morphe i walk
around town with sons about paul murphy
people say what are you doing then they
realize yeah with the rook on aaa the
only piece not really participating in
the attack rook to d8 i think morphe
would be really proud of that move and
true enough and by the way
you know in all the summer camps that
we we teach here at the st louis chess
club and scholastic center is we say
chess is a team game
get everybody involved make sure you've
given invitations to every one of your
pieces so you really can't criticize the
move rook ad8 at all and queen c6 may be
a better move for specific reasons but
that is good if somebody goes down on
the team there's always a beautiful
replacement
there you go now you were about to bring
up again uh the game between timor
garriev yeah and i was surprised because
the players followed their suggestions i
always like what that happens after
bring those games up it doesn't happen
very often well ben these guys are
really good yeah that's true we have to
give them some kudos okay so we like
graves position because he was going to
advance in the center and you were
looking for counter play with the move
b5 right and that's exactly what
happened white played f4 as i suggested
and black played b5 as you suggested so
both sides were following their plans
and after the trade
well white didn't really want to trade i
guess and take on e7
because of this rook e8 and the e4 pawn
is a bit loose
right thanks to the knight on c5 this
seems like black's getting good counter
play now i agree so instead of doing
that
go back to the game position he just
played rook f3 it's funny one of the
byproducts of f4 attacking is it gives
the rook on f4 some squares so we can
get out of the way of the bishop on b5
well jennifer who is not here again
because of allergies
she she would not let this
opportunity pass without saying rover
rook up and over rover it's actually not
clear to me where the rook is going to
go over it could go either direction
so
okay so rook f3 the bishop went back to
a6
black wants to keep his nice bishop on
the diagonal and not give white the two
bishops makes sense
and e5 wow
right away yeah timor
is he's making a big statement
uh he's looking to push uh daniel right
off the board with the move e
for e5 maybe we can disagree for the
first time although i think it's
unlikely i really like white's position
you know
i i do too but if you said to me the
computer thought it was only .88
i'd say okay that's fair i i liked uh
lenderman's position much much more than
gaudy has but yes we both still see that
white's in the driver's seat daniel's
got to come up with some
good moves to get out of his situation
if he plays a move like queen d7
that would be the first move you look at
get out of the way of this get out of
the way of this scary rook very scary
now do you go for e6 or do you try to
plant a rook on the 7th with rookie 7
coming who takes in rookie 7 or e6 also
possible is a move like bishop c2 just
trying to build a little more keeping
control f5 control e4 put the bishop on
a little better square
and um well slowly but surely break
through
maybe the rover will be with a move like
like uh rook rook on f to e3
and then try to break through on the
seventh rank this way there's a lot of
good possibilities for wyatt exactly the
one one move i didn't think that was
that threatening was bishop c2 the
reason is because of a specific defense
that black has here
the move i have in mind is f7 f6
and i think
i have enough defensive resources if you
take on f6 for example then i'll i'm
quick to challenge on the e file i don't
see this as a problem i would be very
tempted to play e6 here which i kind of
like because i've lured your pawn
forward and keep the e file closed i'll
step back with the queen queen yes d-8e
i want to sacrifice here somehow
but i don't have my friend houdini to
help me exactly my friend's off doing
other work
helping alex lundgren
and after bishop h4 i was thinking f6 f5
and the position just suddenly
got closed like just like that
and black's
i think has reasonable prospects of
holding
this position what has been played by
the way
oh who's work played in the game so
let's
update our
board
again a very uh tense
battle here and i'm sure the game is
going to be decided
something very interesting has happened
so after e5 yeah
the frightening move he played the move
queen to b8 wow
offering upon the other side of the
board now we saw this yesterday
in his game with josh riedel daniel in a
very difficult position
you know
the shocking move before right threw
away upon and here he's sort of like
he's throwing away a big center pawn
that juicy pawn on e7 but not juicy
enough for correa
who plays the move f5 wow okay
really sharp now
talk about breaking through in the
center
okay i thought that this move f5 was
going to be prefaced by bishop c2
t-morse saw no reason why he doesn't
want to just go for it i guess his idea
is if in case of bishop e5 there may be
a tactic against the knight on c5 ben
i was thinking of bishop e7 rook e8 and
then takes e5 exactly and
uh bad things happened to that knight on
c5 if you yeah when all the pieces are
away from black's king
e5 f5 usually works out pretty well yeah
and by the way notice that that queen on
d2 is lurking ready to hop skip and jump
to h6 and then we can have one of
jennifer's rovers now we know what the
rover is we're all set yeah
well that would be overkill queen b
moving away from the king looks a little
a little risky but probably
underestimated f5 thinking i'm
sacrificing a point on e7 i'll get
counter play down the e file i'll play
queen to b4
and i'll get my play you know everywhere
but just f5 and
kill kill kill
not taking pawns but attacking the king
wow so let's see that move this situate
the current situation again so uh
daniel noradiski
u.s junior champion under
serious uh direction over at his u.s
junior champion picture right next to
him oh yes overseeing his own play those
are the pictures of the juniors from
last year exactly
and i do believe that we're about ready
to get an insight from maurice uh this
very very tense game going on here
between timor garriev and daniel norris
nordicky
this round three battle is really
heating up and even though we didn't see
any draws yesterday my money is we're
going to see a fair number of decisive
games in this the third round maurice
take it away tell us what you got i said
at the top looking at the way the games
went yesterday and then looking at the
matchups today it just felt like today
would be bloodbath day like this had to
be some victories and already we see
lindemann just ripping apart ramirez in
his game and just effortlessly doing so
what's funny is it's the kind of game
guys that we'll use with our students in
the future if he gets it to the finish
line we'll say wow this is the kind of
game we can use although oddly we'll
have to explain king f8 h6 and h5 and
why that was justified still scratching
my head over that one however
this game
also looks totally dominant for white
like classic it's raining pawns look at
these three white pawns however the
computer's saying
that's not that big an advantage i mean
it's big it's big enough that he should
feel good about himself but black can
play different ways and keep it at about
.57 that's pretty big in computer speak
but still not so big that you would you
think what black has just lost the move
queen to b6 with a very transparent
little discovered attack is possible
here and to move king to h1 the most
normal and considered best move here and
now check this funky idea out just take
on e5 with the pawn and after bishop
takes e7 rook over to e8
pawn to f6 hello we're coming in now
crunch a munch
the sudden petrossianesque
rook sacrifice named after the champion
tigran petrosian who became champion in
1966 he used to sacrifice exchanges like
this all the time so that he could get
an exchange down position but with
possible defensive chances this is what
the computer is giving as possibility
for black that now it's saying it's
still 0.6 giving the nod to the rook but
we know this dark squared bishop is
pretty tough to break down now with all
those dark square uh pawns
dark square control
this one's not so easy i wouldn't feel
that comfortable winning this position
with the white pieces so hidden
possibilities here for naraditsky that
may save him the game
back to you guys
that's a nice nice nice exchange
sacrifice
and really in the style of tigran
petrosian but queen b6
if we put that move up on the board like
this move because it defends the c5
knight in some of your trickier
variations right playing bishop e7
bishop c5 and everybody would play king
h1 uh just as that's a very normal human
move d takes e5 bishop takes e7
one of the positions that
would scare me if i was black after
rookie 8
is i get i get frightened by this
dominant knight on e4 right i agree f6
rookie 7 is a great exchange sacrifice
idea that maurice pointed out
it's a judgment call of course but after
bishop takes c5
kind of a
variation that you would see in a lot of
benoni's and let's say knight e4
you just have to say to yourself okay i
got this great dark square bishop that's
defending my king
oh
queen d4 is actually a very good move
i'm thinking rook d3 is the answer and
against queen b4 i planned queen f2
the queen d4
thinks that that bishop on a3 and that's
that's too bad that doesn't get my
the positional grip in the that i wanted
with the great knight on e4 and then
everything goes uh
over to the king side so black has a
little better defensive resources than
you would think at first because it
looks like he's sort of getting smooshed
in the center shmooshed is a good
good
way a good descriptive uh way so still
daniel
not in the terrible shape that i was
fearing but still he doesn't look too
shabby
daniel does not look pleased with this
he's very serious at the chessboard i he
he dominated the usg junior championship
and and during many of his games he
didn't look very happy uh but it looks
like he just played f6 if i could see
the monitor correctly wow now that's
after f5 so let's go back did not play
the move queen b6 as the computer was
suggest
suggesting in the lines that we were
looking at
i was thinking of this move f6 by the
way in a different type of position
uh a move or two ago
here i'd be a little bit fearful that
i'm not
there's some sacrifice against the g6
square
and our rover uh really starts to
look good with the bishop c2 i'm sure
maurice has got something to say about
this move f7 f6 because he got excited i
see you out of the corner of my eye
quickly oh and the moves are coming
faster
okay maurice you
jump in quick
well
just like you guys i didn't like f6 uh
f6 looks like it's burying your bishop
on g7 it looks like it's compromising
the pawn structure and that's just to my
human eyes well
the computer agrees f6 is not a good
move it's
increased white's advantage now with
that move and e takes on f6
e takes back on f6 and it's saying you
know what this position is simply
horrible for black
the pieces are bad a move like bishop h6
it's suggesting and it's giving a 0.99
that's a 0.99 it's it's like i'm almost
at one once i get to one it means you're
done for sure but a 0.99 advantage to
to white here saying that this this is
just ugly what's happening over here to
the structure believe it or not after it
was given more thought more time to
think in this position here after f5 we
saw queen b6 as one move the computer
was daring enough to believe that even
this move was powerful and maybe even
better than than queen b6 giving only a
0.38 advantage to white here saying that
the the disadvantage had been minimized
why because this knight is prepared to
go to the e5 square which was weakened
by this pawn push i know it seems hard
to believe though but after f6
seems like white should have a ton of
good moves here and this trade the
computer actually liked black's chances
here because it felt like there was no
mating attack anymore
f6 had clogged up the position and now
we can go to the e file i have my doubts
about this position guys i mean
especially this pawn burying this bishop
but it could become a little bit of a
target in this position and it's not
clear what white does to improve the
game so
judgment by the computer it's going to
have to show me this line i don't doubt
that it would but then again it does
have this nice square and the ability to
bring the rook to the file
still the move f6 and queen b6 was
definitely a more solid alternative but
the move f6 not the move you wanted to
play here that's why timor just took so
quickly plus he was going to lose his
pawn anyway so the trade has happened
and it's really wide for choice here in
this position back to you guys
thank you maurice right on with my whole
approach it's interesting with the move
bishop h6 and rook e7 and you know
you're thinking mate mate
if you don't mate black can make a
blockade
i see maybe ben you have a different
point of view i see this bishop on g7 i
said that's an ugly bishop why don't you
just keep it yeah it's always yours how
about bishop e3
followed by bishop c2 and start really
powerful just play against this bishop
on g7 right now you did it i didn't and
that that that's a passive looking
bishop
i mean okay black will play of course
moves like queen b4 rookie 8
i don't know other 97 95 but i'm
thinking
leave that bishop on the board bishop h6
is very concrete very direct because you
want to play rookie seven what would
your approach be if you had timor's
position i wish i had such a pleasant
choice
h6 is the more concrete move to try to
increase your advantage quickly and
bishop e3 is just saying yeah the next
20 moves you can have your bishop on g7
and i'm going to slowly end different
folks
different strokes for different folks i
don't know i personally i like bishop h6
rookie 7 rook h3 i think i can come get
you i think i can get you quick but i
yeah your way of playing is it just
seems like f6 was a poor move a poor
choice yeah i really like maurice's
knight to d7 taking advantage of white
playing f5 giving up the e5 square this
kind of retreat we don't see that very
often once you've well you want to play
knight c5 or knight e5 and once you
found one of them you don't usually go
back to the other but
with white playing the move f5 exceeding
control of the e5 score this is a very
interesting idea
to get the knight back defending the
king so probably his position wasn't as
bad as he thought it seems like by the
body language both players like white
quite a bit because it just seems like
white is going forward on the king side
and black has very little counter play
very good all right more tidbits from
maurice maurice what do you got for us
yes guys in a game we haven't been
following too closely i'd like to take a
look at the game between the youngster
the youngest player in this competition
ashrita eswaran she was playing the
white pieces here and you know how
themes pop up and then they just keep
popping up as like
somehow something unusual we think we
won't see it again and then we see it in
the exact same round very funny incident
happened here as well i just want to go
back a little bit just to show the
position we had this complex position at
one point black played a very nice
instructive maneuver put the knight on
a6 and after bishop to d2 put the other
knight on d7 fighting for that c5 square
black played sorry white played c3 and
after knight to c5 a trade of knights
happened the queen went to c4 and now
the veteran camilla played bishop to g5
trading off the dark squared bishops
showing that she understands positional
chess she wants to have the superior
minor piece after this trade the bishop
took on g5 and then c takes b4 c takes
b4 it was impossible to take on b4 now
because of the move knight to d3 thank
you very much for the exchange
by the way i say impossible it you could
pull this off and now this is the point
that i wanted to make later so instead
of doing that queen takes b4 and maybe
fight the exchange down position but
with those pawns the youngster played
bishop to e2 and after rook fba b3 very
solid and now f5 here come the pawns
queen to c2 94 bishop to c4
rook to a5 and in this position i was
looking at the position i said
just quickly and instinctively i said
kill the knight right this moment you
could have played the exchange sacrifice
and blocks better slightly in this
position but the first move the computer
gives
sack the exchange maybe get to
petrossian get kudos to petrosian for
playing this kind of chess this position
it says minimal advantage to black and
you look at it this a pawn is going to
be a problem forever those rooks are not
easy
will not easily find a file to dominate
this is really the only one but that can
be shut down it looks like with f3 and
real defense so white would have had
absolutely great chances in this
position to defend and maybe even one
day make this uh pony go home and in
fact now the position the computer given
more time to analyze is saying
this position is fine for white this is
okay little advantage to black and not
to the rook but not by much so she
missed an exchange sacrifice here to
save herself or to at least minimize the
disadvantage and now she's stuck in this
position right now when she cannot
sacrifice the exchange here because
after pawn takes she can't play queen
takes pawn because she on her very last
move put her rook on c1 so instructive
theme of the exchange sacrifice she'll
no doubt hear that from her coaches
later uh this thematic defensive idea
but she's still in a big fight between
the oldest woman in the competition and
the youngest back to you guys wonderful
wonderful battle of ideas and for me
chess has uh so many challenges that
i've always
you know struggled with but that that
duel of the bishop versus the knight
which piece is better the bishop or the
knight at first at first sight uh i
thought camilla was doing great after
bishop g5 the knight on c5 looks like a
monster piece
later in the analysis that maurice
showed the bishop on c4 can be very
useful and definitely sacrifice exchange
outstanding battle between the youngest
and the oldest uh
competitors in the women's championship
yeah in a very double-edged you know
night or type position we're apt to see
such kind of
positional exchange sacrifices for both
sides a lot of times in the sicilian we
see black sacrifice in the exchange
exactly here with the beautiful knight
on e4 right which has the c3 and the c5
squares attacking f2 boy sacrificing for
that knight takes a lot of white's
problems away
but maybe she'll get a chance later to
sacrifice and she won't miss it this
time yeah rookie four and rookie one
yeah um
has our co-leader uh
lenderman yeah lenderman's been they've
been taking some things here
end game with this one
how did this happen here let's go back a
few moves you tell me so wow that's
they've made a lot of moves since we
last look okay uh after rook a to d8
right which we okay which that was the
last move we learned a d1 defending
queen c6 which was a movie could have
played previously right which was wow
that was
really difficult to defend this knight
on e4 right bishop e3
what a tactical move rook takes d8 check
his own uh
the agenda discovered attack the bishops
are attacked but london must have had
this figured out right rick takes g1
queen takes d4 he wants to play queen d8
check and take this guy but that's just
not going to happen no
three
now you got to go queen d8 check no
choice there
uh just show the you trade queens to
show why f takes e3 would have been a
poor choice f takes e3 bishop takes e3
check is good i'm assuming taking on
on e4 is probably also good there might
be some perpetual check idea
well
but this looks good i can play knight f2
but i don't want to have white in this
position
my eyes hurt all right that was not
played queen d a check
only move by the way queen eight we
couldn't go king f7 have a forced queen
trade oh right unfortunately white has a
lot of pieces hanging it's still
terrible all of them every white piece
is attacked and white is down a piece
very good
knight d6 check only move king d7 we
have to take the knight
yep otherwise uh and probably black has
more than one way to win but bishop a3
is pretty nice bishop h3 i should say
bishop h3 the rook and the knight and
white played a surprising move here
knight f5
i was thinking that he had to play rook
to d1 although i guess
bishop e3 and bishop g4 might be quite
annoying
because
that's a beautiful quite quite annoying
a thematic uh checkmating threatening
rook and threatening
bishop f3-8 well show the mate because
this is the classical two bishop mate
against a castle you don't get to do
this every day no you don't and when it
happens it's really sweet
and that
obviously alejandro could yeah so
alejandro played knight f5 and just went
into an exchange down ending but
no compensation at all
h4 interesting i thought g6 to try to
yeah that would be like the most normal
move i guess okay but this might be h4
looks good like really
great because if you if your rook can
blast its way to uh
the first or second rank i mean it's
it's a beautiful preparation in a
beautiful game by bill endermen who we
think is probably going to win before
move 40. exactly
and
we haven't seen
our
number one seed
in tournament
pre-tournament favorite defending
champion
gotta kamsky he is playing against the
young ray robson trying to earn
a reputation as well as a seat
on our u.s olympic team
that game when we left it ray
surprisingly enough was playing in
kamsky style establishing a central bind
uh trying to trying to milk some squares
um we thought that gotta had a
a fortress like position but it still
felt to us that ray was for choice
what's the current setup situation
because the current position seems like
white has a nice position
komski has his usual blockade i'm trying
to draw
and uh well komski has a big time
advantage which i think we both would
have we would have guessed um ray's
doing better this round though 13
minutes to make 15 moves that's not so
bad
so much better yeah he's sweating
cannonballs but okay
he's he's super happy and of course and
the 32nd increment that's important yeah
uh ray will get 30 seconds for each i
think we well i won't speak for you i'd
rather have white in this position but
okay black is probably defending yeah
and uh what were the last two moves so
we can just get an idea of where
where uh yeah so ray was playing a3 b4
gaining space on the queen side right
and after the trade kamsky decided to
take over the a file instead of fighting
for the e file which he had and he
says i'll take the e file okay and now
queen to f8 okay
and is ray still thinking in this
position this is the current position so
basically ray opened the a file and
komski took over ray took over the e
file and
obviously white has a small space
advantage on the queen side still quite
an annoying pawn here on d5 right making
black sort of passive
it's not really clear clear to me where
black's pieces can go the knight on f6
bishop on d7 aren't super active but
can i really improve them put them on
better squares yeah i mean if i were
white i would want to try to stick my
knight on the c6 where knight d4 to
c6 but that i'd have to probably preface
it with a bishop f5 move trying to trade
a bishop
trying to take away the defender of the
c6 square still like ghada let's see
what maurice has to share in this the
third round of the u.s
national championships here from st
louis
hey guys i have a position on the board
that's interesting the reason i called
it interesting you'll see in a moment
this game is between one of our
co-leaders sabino foiser against
four-time women's national champion anna
zatonski now i go
back here calling it interesting this is
move five in the game you're like move
five dude we're almost at the first time
control what are you doing well let's
just follow the game she played the
unusual knight f3 as you mentioned ben
and then moved c5 a3 this exchange
happened and then black castled white
then pinned this knight knight came out
to d7 normal developing moves and why
try to get out the game
with her bishop but queen a5 made her
start to wonder if this knight might not
land on the e4 square all right takes
trade knight takes and now this move
rook to c1 guarding the pawn giving away
the a pawn but maybe there's some tricks
along with bishop to e7 after e4 she
worried about that so she said you know
what let me first test that bishop to
see what it wants to do
simple move the bishop said well i'm not
going anywhere sabine played e4
attacking the knight now suddenly the
board has exploded now according to
houdini the best moment was to actually
take this bishop allowing e takes d5
that kind of line i'm sure none of us
wants to play it's not so easy to to
play uh let me just knock off the
receiving moves here to play takes in
this line and takes and then find this
move knight to f6
very strange move but the point is that
now the knight guards any mate here and
it's trying to open up this line for a
rook and this bishop will spring to life
in the game as well that's a first class
move that's definitely world class all
right but she didn't see that move and
instead she played the move queen c3
much simpler to take here and queen
takes queen and i believe they're in
this position well black should have
probably would
take the queen quite soon uh in this
position now
why i'm bringing this up is look at the
times on the clock already it's only 13
moves and black is at 17 minutes to go
so you were talking about ray ben having
that many moves to play but check this
one out she has to play
27 moves in the next 17 minutes yes she
does have increments i hate increments
by the way i think they totally changed
the game we got to get rid of those
things increments just don't we
americans can't follow increments and i
just don't i think they should be in the
national championship but that said
she will have increments
uh 30 seconds
what is that adding 27 another 13
minutes to the clock maybe 14 minutes to
the clock
but nevertheless she still has to make a
lot of moves a half an hour in 27 moves
in half an hour so you know both sides
are going to feel the pressure sabine is
not that much better at 27 minutes
herself as a matter of fact so it's a
real challenge for both players we're
going to follow this game probably in
the next half hour there's going to be
some real explosions happening on the
chessboard back to you guys well thank
you for that maurice uh before the
competition and during one of her
interviews anna said that she came to
the game it came to the tournament
pardon me a little bit rusty hadn't been
playing much chess and usually when
you're getting into time trouble this
bad time trouble this early it's an
example of that rustiness
what we're going to do now is go to our
second puzzle of the day the from the
famous 1964 u.s championship where bobby
fischer swept the field clean sweep 11-0
where hopefully get you
a better puzzle
it will be the game between bobby
fischer and byrne
and bobby fisher to play and to win see
if you can solve it
thereafter we'll take a break it'll be a
little bit longer break 10 to 15 minutes
thank you
so
chess championships
here in st louis the chess capital of
the united states
uh first of all thank you everybody for
all your
comments and suggestions we do have one
of our sponsors chess.com giving away
diamond memberships to the best uh
questions and comments
i've looked them over thank you i agree
with many of your cells who are
explaining that this is a real real
battle and the championships
and the championships are really heating
up
we'd like to go right away to that
graphic of the game between uh robert
byrne and bobby fischer in his epic 11-0
sweep 50 years ago and maurice is going
to take us step by step through the
action of how bobby fischer defeated
robert byrne
well there we saw that move on the board
a truly scintillating bone crunching
move
fischer played knight takes f2
bam this kind of move is fantastic
because it just rips apart the king's
defense now burn thought there would be
no problem you know okay you got a
couple of pawns for the exchange i'm
gonna shift my queen over you know go
ahead take your rook what you gotta say
and fisher said um
actually no
i'm going to take this bishop and that
was truly the all-star move this move
actually when you play it a lot of
computers when they first see it they go
what what that's not the best and then
they go uh oh
the guy's a genius it is the best move
because after you get this piece back
then this move another sacrifice d4
undermining this nice protection of this
knight look at that rook and bishop so
you must trade and then the next move
queen to d7 sorry no bishop to b7 check
forcing the king back
and now queen to d7
and this position by the way i should
point out this line if you put the king
back directly
then you run into the simple bishop
takes d4 check and if you try to get
that piece back
oops
rook check and now rook takes rook runs
into queen takes queen and if you move
your king away then we start with queen
takes queen and then pick off this rook
in the corner so white would be down in
exchange and upon definitely losing
against the likes of bobby fischer so
against bishop b7 check white had to
play king to f1 and now the winning move
queen to d7 now it's a funny story here
because the position is actually
completely lost
uh donald robert byrne looked at this
position thought about it for some time
and resigned meantime in the
commentating room the grand masters were
saying oh this is bad for black black's
losing and when they saw donald byrne
come in the room they were like what
happened did you win and he's like no
dude i lost what are you talking about
and they couldn't understand it they
were looking at the variation with queen
f2 but this line doesn't work to queen
check and after the king moves in the
corner the spectacular shot
rook to e1 check and this move is just
brutal because if the queen captures
obviously the queen is busy stopping
mate on g2 and if the rook captures well
the rook has to capture then bishop
takes d4 dragging the queen away for
that juicy mate on g2 so a spectacular
victor victory by fischer one that is
remembered by all of us in the annals of
chess beautiful beautiful game one of
those games too that when everybody
started they're like this guy
he's the real deal and of course he went
on a few years later eight years later
to be exact to become the world champion
back to you guys in the studio
thank you maurice and that was a
definite result it had a big impression
that game left a big impression on me
and i spent a lot of time trying to
dissect and understand that game
speaking of results we do have two
results
in the open
we have two draws ben
ray robson gotta kamsky ended in draws
and
onishok
and a cobian and yeah
repetitions in both positions um let's
go back a few moves in the in the robson
game
so what happened was we were explaining
how white was controlling one file and
black was controlling the other well
gotta kept fighting for the file and
he just repeated the moves rook e8 rook
a8 and white didn't want to trade rooks
because that would lead closer to a draw
so white was fighting for the file and
god is like no
and eventually after repetition with
having less time on the clock very
understandable black having a slightly
worse position probably
and yeah ray came in the studio and he's
like yeah i thought i was better but i
don't really see any way to improve my
position nice another sort of solid draw
for ghada
just a repetition by the way defending
champion godakamsky
was strong in last year's u.s
championship out of the box with four
wins after four rounds here starting
with three
draws not impeccable draws mind you the
three draws
um
that title is up for stakes and then the
other result was between
accobian and onishuk and how did that
that's right they also had repetition
but theirs was a a diagonal repetition
oh my god so let's go back a few moves
yeah it was a pretty equal game
throughout whitehead the two bishops but
look how solid black's position is
and what ended up happening was
bishop attacked the queen
the bishop came back to the center and
now white's black is threatening knight
to b3
that wouldn't be any fun for white so
white played queen to d1
bishop to b3 and they had this kind of
repetition with black always threatening
knight b3 and white preventing it with
queen d1 and okay very solid position
for black the two bishops for white but
it looks like quite a nice position so a
solid draw from both players probably
both players satisfied with the result
all right and in the game between our
young phenom
and
the veteran of the women's championship
camilla uh back in skyrim that game has
gotten really totally blown up what has
happened we left it
a few moves ago expecting some kinds of
exchange sacrifices to occur that did
not happen right we thought white at
some point would sacrifice the exchange
and take away most of black's winning
chances but instead white had other
ideas jennifer would be proud the rover
is coming rook up and over rookie 3
the rook went to a1 behind the past pawn
black doesn't want that pawn to advance
but now the black queen isn't on the
king's side anymore so white had a very
interesting idea of dislodging this
knight on e4 by playing king h1 wow and
then the super aggressive g4 wow
brought back a flash for me
from the 1992 match between the rematch
i want to say between bobby fischer and
boris baskey where bobby played this
move g4 under mining and knight and uh
and let's talk about our heels now we've
got to defend against the past apon and
against the king side attack absolutely
this knight's not as strong as we
thought it was maybe it's going to get
attacked exactly
so rook went back to c7 to
come defend on the king's side and also
open up the line for the black queen
right gf gf and rick f3 like putting
tremendous pressure
on the advanced placement of black's
pieces right rook f8
rick g1 check
black trades rooks right and now bishop
to d3
undermining the knight every single
white piece attacking the black
structure here
and also if somehow we trade a lot of
pieces over here the king of pawn
endings not looking good for black
so white has an attack on the king's
side white's undermining black center
and white has that past a pawn just in
case wow
looks tough for camilla uh
does the move queen d4 is that a move
that could that camilla might essay or
she has it seems like she has to defend
the night on e4 somehow also camilla
having a time disadvantage which we've
seen before in this tournament let's see
if we have an update on any of the moves
i see eight million
pardon me i see in fact only two and a
half minutes for camilla versus uh 36
minutes for eswaran and the young
debutant um you know i'm worried queen
d4 might go into one of these kingdom
pawn endings that's not very good right
if i capture this knight if you capture
it with the pawn which was my very
worried about queen c7 check
i'm scared
with good reason i don't know if it's
good but i'll take white king g8 and
there's a quick checkpoint g three check
and queen g seven minutes oh my i hate
when that happens go
so yeah and the other problem with queen
d4 is if you take with the queen
are we in time to stop this a pawn
even if we are does it matter no i
i don't think it does
fight a pawn is just winning for a while
king a7 king so if queen d4 is not
possible very logical move with very
little time on the clock this seems like
a very difficult position for for
camilla and it looks like the position
in fact is collapsing for camilla
and what a shocker in round three
maurice i'm sure you have some more
insights you'd like to share in this
round
indeed yes that particular position has
caught my eye as well so i decided to
explore it let's just bring it up right
here and in this position
this position we had back
here black was just fine black was doing
okay right
and
so black started wavering though black
started making some moves we saw this
position rook takes e4 was possible but
white played rook to c1 and then
couldn't do it so they played a few more
moves and black tried to be very solid
and then she decided nothing was
happening on this side so let's switch
sides y played king h1 and now put the
queen on b6
also not a bad decision
however
g4
very radical very interesting and might
have been wrong in fact because black
had a crazy
exchange sacrifice and maybe she
couldn't have calculated to the finish
because this line is absolutely not
clear obviously queen takes runs into
knight takes f2 check and there goes a
rook so that line would not have worked
however
here rook takes c4 b takes is playable
but now black could play this move pawn
up to b3 and again
white is under tremendous pressure her
position is very stretched she could
play queen to b2 blocking everything and
now the move queen d4 offering a trade
of queens this would have been extremely
dangerous for white in this position i
looked at the end game going down
another 15 moves it's razor's sharp
because queen takes pawn takes now you
drop the rook back and after pawn up
then rook here and the lines go d3 with
a trade and a trade and now black
pushes and you can't stop this pawn so
you have to sacrifice for it and the
lines go you try to run this night well
let's do it pawn up this knight comes
back this can stop you here and then
trade on this side or i think you could
have traded traded earlier and that's
the question if this king can get over
versus this king mopping up these pawns
so very deep even now houdini's saying
yeah it's a piece up but that a pawn is
really really strong holding down that
knight so that was a chance for camilla
but maybe she couldn't calculate all of
it and even then she wouldn't have had a
winning position so that's why she chose
the lines that you guys started looking
at and now she's in this position
jumping to the current position
and the youngster having
dodged that bullet of the rook takes c4
computers saying we really like white
.73 right now definitely game turnaround
and it looks as though white is clearly
in the driver's seat
king is fine
trades might happen and that a pawn we
talked about it a long time ago she has
that strong a pawn on the board and it's
up to her now to find out what to do
with this position it seems as though a
move has been played so let's see if we
can bring the position up to date the
move
rook f6
just giving away the pawn
bishop takes pawn takes queen takes
there's nothing wrong with that that's
just
a free pawn
and the young 13 year old would have a
huge advantage in that position and
she's done it she has taken the pawn she
is clearly now dominating in this
position with a winning endgame after
queen takes e4
definitely in trouble is black in this
position and also in time trouble a huge
edge 34 minutes to only 1 and 46 for
black so
given this position you know
you guys and myself we're thinking this
is over let's see if the 13 year old
could pull off a second victory here at
the u.s women's championship back to you
guys thank you maurice i just wanted to
say that eswaran
was invited to the competition it's a
big big big test we as the organizers at
the st louis chess club and scholastic
center were a little bit worried
throwing this young bambi to these
grizzled veterans who wanted the new
blood and guess what the new blood said
i didn't get that memo i'm playing and
if she wins this game she'll have won
two out of three
and
clearly a force
not only in this tournament but in the
future u.s championships very important
that's always worrisome about inviting a
young up-and-coming talented player
they're not used to strong players
strong players strong player strong
player when you play in swisses if you
lose a game your next opponent's a
little bit easier so if you lose one or
two or three games in a row you can
really start feeling it but she won her
first game in a marathon game right she
lost a difficult game to irena and here
she's back on the horse and
wow she's really playing well and looks
like she's on her way to her second
victory that would be amazing fantastic
can we just check in with the game of
our tournament co-leader in the open
section
um
mr lenderman
we've praised his uh opening preparation
throughout alejandro made it to the time
control
an achievement
and what how did he get here when we had
left it black was breaking let's go back
h5 h4
we were back so after h4 white played
the simple king g2 all right stopping
the black rook from infiltrating got it
trade and this looks like should be a
pretty easy win for black yep
h6
and this just seems like the technical
phase of the game some players might
even resign here with white but okay why
resign before move 40 when you don't
have to exactly
b6 a little strange move but okay very
safe all right making sure we don't lose
any of our pawns relocates his bishop
very sensibly
take white having four isolated pawns
and down an exchange
and now he's going to defend his g pawn
with his king so his rook can start
moving around exactly so
41 king g7 and then the rook is released
to go over back to the wide open
frontier that we see on the
uh queen side i don't know what houdini
says but i'm thinking this is plus three
yeah because if white tries to get some
counter play this doesn't work because
bishop f2 is just
yes his lights out let's just go to
maurice for a quick moment to see what
whether our guess about houdini is
accurate or not maurice can you tell us
absolutely yes this position is
definitely busted for black it's for
white it's just a question of time there
it's probably taking alex longer than he
wanted that is lenderman longer than he
wanted for it to take he probably wants
this guy to resign you know i'm winning
come on now you're spoiling my miniature
well nobody's going to do you any favors
i remember uh grandmaster crush when she
came in it had taken her a lot of moves
after she won an exchange to finally win
the game and she felt badly about it she
said it took me so long and lenderman
himself said actually you know i went i
looked at it with the computer it said
that you played very strong moves your
advantage was always going up and up and
up so you didn't have to worry that it
actually took 60 moves although you won
an exchange 30 moves ago so that lesson
is planted firmly in his mind from two
rounds ago so no doubt he's sitting
there thinking i don't care how long it
takes i'm going to win this game and
it's going to be a point and uh i'll be
the leader in the competition he just
has to relax and let it happen now
there's another position though i'm
really fascinated by because i don't get
it victoria knee against uh alyssa
malaquina and in this position in
terrific time pressure with only two
minutes on the clock is this a glitch
piece under attack the knight is
why not sack it knight takes on e5
but
queen takes e5
is just a piece
and
so houdini is saying
what gives you just handed me a piece
for no reason so the sacrifice just
looks like a blunder unless you guys see
some miracle that i don't uh houdini
doesn't see it so i'll just give you
that hint don't even bother looking it's
just a piece but what's the rationale
behind giving up this piece in this
position i really don't know it looks as
if it was just a time pressure blunder
so alyssa milikina with the right moves
should be getting off the schneider from
zero points which she's lost two games
and winning her first game at the u.s
women's championship back to you
guys in the studio
thank you maurice i
what can i say but time
time trouble makes fools out of
everyone and sometimes you just have
that you know like the you sudden mental
jolt that you've got to move
and maybe in that particular position
she's dreaming of some fantasy bishop c4
check where the king will the black king
is forced on the diagonal of the bishop
on b2
unfortunately it doesn't seem to be
there
and victoria's sacrifice should not work
out ben you have other games that you
have uh under your screen
there's a lot of interest here um i want
to go back to the
the ehrenberg game all right
that's actually
sam shanklin
with sam shanklin and it seems like a
really heavyweight positional struggle
and ruby lopez
sort of equal the whole game trading
equalizing but i sort of i sort of like
black position a little bit now because
black has a nicer rook than white and
the b pawn is a little bit weaker than
the c pawn so
sam having his usual time advantage due
to his good preparation
and it seems like although i didn't like
the opening choice because i thought
ehrenberg would that would be his type
of position it seems like sam's played
the game very nicely and he's the one
who's probably trying to press for a win
very nice and who is to play in the
position that we have just played knight
to f4
and you were explaining earlier that
black would try to somehow get one or
both of his knights to d3 they have to
play f6 first to defend his e pawn as a
preparatory man the v2 pawn is even
weaker absolutely no if if uh sam
can get in the moves f7 f6 knight
d7 c5 the graphic that you've got on the
board he's in the driver's seat i mean
that's a dream position because actually
the bishop on c2 is
a passive piece that means that pawn on
e4
um
it looks like all of white's pieces are
passive exactly so sergey in trouble in
this game and needs to come up with a a
good equalizing plan and maybe at some
point he may have to go
um
with a crazy a crazed rook a7 rook takes
seat
b2 rook takes d7 kind of idea
probably prefaced first with g2 g3 but i
can easily see this
game turning
like that and then you just don't get
out with uh with white ehrenberg
defended really nicely yesterday in a
much worse position against ownership so
he'll have to do it again but if you're
asked to do it every round that's that's
no fun at all it'll catch up defending
against robson defending against
shankland worst positions he can't
always draw all of them and
he's going to have to it's his first us
championship he doesn't know the other
players as well and well he's finding
out that uh there's some tough players
in this tournament and we do have some
moves so if you could bring us up the
date on what the players have played
and again i do see that big time
differential four minutes versus 20
minutes for sam i think he played g3
yeah you got to get rid of that knight
that knight on f4 is just and sam has
just played 96
very nicely dropping back and by the way
d3 square we've got the d4 square we've
got all the squares got a lot of squares
and
here i'm thinking that sergey is going
to need to move light
well once again rook a 2 to a7
hoping that you'll go rook takes b2 rook
takes c2 and maybe i can swindle a draw
out of that but definitely sam uh in
good shape in this round yeah and the
time situation better than i thought for
sam 20 minutes to five
so time trouble once again difficult you
can see aaron berg not very comfortable
five minutes i gotta defend this
position and if i play perfectly then
i'll draw right yay yay and other games
uh take us around with the ladies
championship how has we have left arena
arena arena the battle of the arenas who
is the best arena
in the arena in the arena
wait a second if i'm looking at this
correctly which is always possible
they've been re repeating quite a bit
so let me go back a few moves here
rookie eight rookie two
rookie eight
rookie two oh my that looks like a
repetition so you're saying and the
a draw has been agreed by drawn as we
see on the monitor that was good timing
so rex is feeling a little bit better
because as we know yesterday he did
something uh quite extraordinary he
extended a 64 000 bonus to any lady in
the women's championship that went
uh clean sweep arena was a two-and-oh
starter
she can't win the bonus with a draw and
only sabine foyser shall we take a look
at sabine you know i was having private
talks with rex yesterday and he told me
there was actually a fisher prize for
the commentary team if somebody there's
somebody commentary all 11 rounds and
jennifer's out
so and i missed the first first couple
rounds so it's just left to you mauricio
the only two left well if maurice gets
kneecap don't look at me don't look at
me i had nothing to do with it i had
nothing to do with it
ben how would you like to make 32 000
um sorry maurice no no don't worry don't
worry let's go to maurice to get his
thoughts on that one
yes i got people
watch your back son
i want to jump to a game from the
women's championship that we thought
would be very easy and now it's turned
into a little bit craziness uh in this
position after the sacrifice we saw a
knee in big time trouble decide to
sacrifice her night after queen takes
she played this extraordinary
extravagant move f4 attacking the queen
now it was up to
black to find the right defense or at
least the right approach and it turns
out that she could have just simply
grabbed another pawn let me just turn
this off so i can analyze queen takes on
e4 this move is pure greed this is
saying show me what you got queen takes
e4 and the main lines some funky lines
here but bishops to c4 check and if you
put the king in the corner which is
actually suggested is a a decent move
then rook to e2 suddenly
and
europe queen is in trouble there's
threats along this long diagonal that
you might get mated we saw this kind of
made happen in another position the
lenderman position you guys were
analyzing this diagonal suddenly gets
funky so it turns out bishop to c4 check
you have to be willing to pin yourself
with knight to d5 and in this line
anything like rook to e2 the queen can
just go forward
keeping protection with no worries here
threats on this pawn i say no worries
it's easy for me to say i'm not the one
defending this position but turns out
that black would be not only fine but
giving an advantage is houdini of
3.94
big time almost four points saying
white's attack is bogus i don't believe
it it's not going to work
however
after f4
melikina in a little bit of time
pressure herself played the move queen
to d6 this is still better for her it's
not the same three plus i'm up a piece
kind of thing white does have the move
bishop to c4 check attacking and after
king g7
the computer says white really doesn't
have anything even here so she's still
winning is black but not the same degree
that she could have been winning and now
in uh in some pressure she's going to
have to deal with the position let's see
if we can get to the current position on
the board what has happened is is the
move e5 chasing her queen back the queen
has dropped back to d7 again black is
still winning here up a piece but
a little bit uncertainty in this game we
thought it was just going to be easy
anything but back to you guys
thank you maurice for that boy i didn't
like that move e5 which
kind of killed the bishop on b2 a bit
it's never easy in chess it's never no i
would have tried my best to keep that in
reserve you've got something up on your
screen here
whatever you're looking for it looks
like uh muldner was able to hold the
draw against josh friedel we thought
that white had a very nice position
after that f5
let's go back but it looks like he held
on you know let's go back a few moves
right
they made many moves back even further
even further
so yeah so that knight took on a6 and we
thought this was a very healthy
advantage for white all right and how
did the game proceed and now the rook on
a1 is pretty devastating on the a file
but that's an ugly pawn structure for
everybody yeah it's pawn structure chess
rook c5 white really wants to win those
pawns on the a file and you got to like
the white position white has to have a
nice
a nice plus here because the a pawns are
just weaker than the beep ones c6 pawn
is no great shakes either no no no
kidding mac isn't it but matt kept
trading and trading and trading and
trading
and
it looked like it was nice for white but
somehow he was able to get most of
white's pawns off the board
wow white's a pawn ahead
but not easy it's never easy
black has a nice king black has active
rook and knight and he was able to take
just enough puns off to draw the game
well this is the thing uh even when you
get an advantage in chess the at
this level of the us championships
the players are finding every resource
and he got himself into a night ending
he's going to win back the pawn on c5
and here i think the players agreed to a
draw
and after knight takes c5 it would be
three versus three and the players
both grand masters record very nice
defense from mullner because neither one
of us liked his position very much
impressive indeed wow good first u.s
championship three draws incredible i
really i i i hadn't met mack before the
event but he's really impressing me he's
acquitting himself very well
usually your first u.s championship i
know i was very nervous of my first u.s
championships and uh he's doing very
well
other games ben what else have you got
for us
so let's see we haven't drawn the robson
komsky game we have a draw on this skin
now let's go back to the grave game
because yes they got into an end game
and
that bishop on uh on f8 is a bit
suspicious well that's what we say well
that that was what we were both thinking
that now thanks to the pawn on f6 the
bishop on
g7 was going to be septic for the rest
of the game uh yeah what happened was he
did play the bishop e3 move that you
were suggesting and then training the
bishops and then came rook e8
so timor very has a very nice oh that's
also doubles up some pawns yeah so
basically timor wants to trade off these
other pieces and leave black with this
bishop on g7 that's not very nice for
black
knight e4
one good tactic deserves another
a very sharp move from young niroditsuki
all right and still trading pieces
and i thought maybe black was becoming
okay here but that bishop on g7
just never really got to a good square
now rook c6 is a very annoying move
attacking everything right
rookie 8 attacking the bishop
he gets a pawn but rook c6 yeah it's
just just a very bad position for black
he's just suffering because of the s6
move
and another actual problem for black in
this position is the pawn on a5
is also uh vulnerable to a bishop e1
type of move and then not too distant
we saw graves have a very nice endgame
advantage yesterday against slenderman
probably even nicer than this and wasn't
able to win somehow shocking that he
didn't win
but two in a row i don't think he'll
mess up two endings in a row
and unfortunately for black he traded
off the bishop that wasn't the f8 bishop
all right
activating his rook
and this is the current position this
seems
a dream position for white
all of his pawns are beautifully on
light squares with the exception the h4
black structure is terrible and bishop
e3 trying to kill the bishop even more
on f8 just to keep it under wraps i'm
seeing rook b6 b5
bishop e3 to b6 and i'm seeing that a5
pawn fall for
nothing then i'm going to have then
timor will have two connected past pawns
and should be winning yeah i agree we're
going to cut to a commercial break
and inform you about a very special
tournament that's coming up later this
year in the u.s
million dollars up for grabs in the
million dollar chest tournament
see the commercial
welcome to the world of this surreal
you take the blue pawn and return to the
comfortable world of chess tournaments
as you know them
you take the red pawn and i'll show you
a chess event beyond your wildest
imagination
we're at the scholastics st louis chess
we have had
a number of results already
but first i'm going to throw it to
maurice and ask him to share his
thoughts maurice
well yes
sorry about that technical difficulty
we'll be playing that ad that com that
interview excuse me
quite soon uh however there is some big
news to
report
in this championship remember this
position guys we were saying yeah it's
going to be easy it's going to be no
problem
i look at houdini's evaluation it says
plus
3 for black
white is done white is toast
so i go okay let me make some moves and
as i'm making the moves to see what
should happen all of a sudden houdini is
repeating the position it cannot find a
way to make progress in this position
there's no specific way and i'm and i'm
defending i'm just making moves
it cannot find a way in if you try to
win for example in this position
you play the move bishop to c6 houdini's
next suggestion is rook to h8 and after
knight h4 it says put the rook on b8 and
then after bishop to b5 he said well
let's try to get in on d8 and after
knight f3 it's like
what am i supposed to do so i don't
understand exactly what's happening here
or why there's no easy way in i mean you
would think that some kind of pawn push
to get the job done or maybe
king but it's like the king can't come
in before the rook does i can't believe
this but it's a weird situation that's
happened here where the computer can't
find a win even though it's saying that
the position is obviously clearly
winning on another development and
another game we see this one eswaran now
has a queen ending very attractive queen
ending an exposed king she just has to
make sure there's no perpetual checks
and she can continue with moves like
check and a move like h4
because no trades are really possible
here move like queen check would run
into queen g5 check with huge problems
obviously the outside pass pawn would
win the game so again we see on
different boards
good endings look like they're winning
real challenges for lindeman in a
position that we really surprised by
because he could have played differently
and his rook d8 just going for the
exchange may not have been the most
accurate but now he has to figure out
how does he win
a position that looked like he should
have won a long time ago
back to you guys it's one of those
situations where your opponent manages
to create some kind of strange fortress
it's like a light square complex versus
a dark square complex and uh alejandro
is getting more chances to save the game
than he deserves it's never easy
it's not seems easy the computer might
say it's easy but it's easy i did want
to say to everybody
that that interview with rex singfield
will be aired we've got it taped it was
a great interview rex really shows
we promise you we will get it on but in
the meanwhile as we get that
set up we do have our guest that's just
coming into
our studio we'll be interviewing him
shortly um
ben if you could just bring up that game
of victoria's once again because that
was a game that i thought was going to
be decided uh very shortly and i think
we're going to see a decisive result in
this game as well yeah i thought
actually
white had resigned here isn't white down
a queen for a piece
all right how did we get this position
yeah let's go back a few
if it's already so after the peace
sacrifice followed by f4 and you didn't
like the movie
because we're
we're really blocking out our chances
here with this bishop on the diagonal
queen d7 bishop g2
knight d5 oh that queen's not very
healthy here on b6 oh my
and e6
every every move is sacrifice
and then rook takes c6 but there is that
check
oh
queen e3 check i hate when that happens
so
probably didn't see that in time trouble
and now the queen
is captured and then c3 and that ends
the game yeah and i think i think here
she resigned i see so
a win for black a nice
victory victor
victoria will be asking herself where
she went wrong in the meanwhile we do
have our guest grandmaster josh friedl
in a store in
in our studio to explain his game today
with maurice
thanks jason i've been told that it's
friedel freedal once and for all we'll
get that right from this moment on so
we're with grand master josh friedel uh
now living in milwaukee originally from
new hampshire uh welcome to the show
thank you so you started off the
championship uh bit rough yeah i was
like i basically had half out of two in
the first two games and i think i should
have had a minimum of one and a half so
given my position so it was a bit
disappointing so i had to come back
today and try not to lose my mind oh
indeed this is a tough championship one
of the strongest ever all gms in the
field uh pretty tough so tell us about
the game today it ended in a draw after
what seemed like a very long and
interesting fight yeah um it was a very
interesting game i decided to play a
fairly aggressive line today
um well i should say actually it's kind
of like a fake out because i play knight
f3 c4 like i'm going to play quietly but
then this particular line can get
extremely sharp
and mack i think very wisely decided not
to go for the really insane
complications which i had prepared and
he probably didn't uh and played a
little bit safer he was he was a bit
worse but um
but at least he's not getting checkmated
out of the opening or anything like this
um so i thought that i held an edge
throughout i thought at some point maybe
i was
at least much better maybe even winning
but i wasn't totally sure
however at the end he found a very nice
defense he played very precisely and i
wasn't able to find a win so whether i
ever had anything significant or not i'm
not sure but it seemed like it was a
fairly well played game now this is
mack's first championship you told me
this is your sixth i was guessing like
two maybe three yeah but six you're a
real veteran of this uh tournament more
or less how do you like the conditions
here playing in st louis no complaints
here that's for sure
um i mean i i've only played in a st
louis u.s championship once um
but uh it's you know one of the best
sites to play chess and i've always
enjoyed my time here so you started off
a little bit slow uh what do you do to
get
rolling in this you know you said you
don't want to go crazy but at some point
you want to start winning some games uh
yeah well to be honest i actually
planned to go crazy today but then he
played a little safer
i mean honestly like i don't think it's
about i need to go crazy to win games
necessarily i think that um the main
problem in my first two games was that
i
you know misplayed a position which was
okay in the first game very slightly
better and then in the second game
completely winning but not very
complicated not an easy win
so i think a lot of it comes down to
calculating a little bit more cleanly
and when i do have my chances playing
more precise chess because i think that
the main issue i've had so far is that
when i have had my opportunities i just
have played in precisely and let my
opponents get back in and needless to
say in a tournament like this you don't
get too many opportunities at all so i
have to cash in a little bit better when
i get them so indeed well we wish you
the best of luck in the rest of the time
grand master josh friedel now living in
milwaukee
and
still fighting still in there only a
half a point
off of even back to you guys
thank you josh and thank you maurice
in the women's championships we went
into the round with two players at
perfect two-and-oh starts
uh arena crush has drawn her round three
game so she is at two and a half points
and sabine
sabina yeah she doesn't like she's doing
very well also at plus two at the start
of the round
uh is in trouble not looking good for
white in this position against anna
zatonski four-time winner anna zatonski
if anna were to win this game
by the way she would be tied with arena
crush so let's take us back a few moves
ben
and we didn't all go wrong very sharp
position early on um even before this
this is where maurice was talking that h
takes g5 variation
and here instead of recapturing on g5
she played the intermezzo to take on d4
trying to be a pawn ahead i was
wondering if white could try to get away
with rick takes ca but that seemed
incredibly dangerous with the kingston
all the pieces still not developed you'd
have two pieces for a rook but black
would have one or two pawns and an
initiative right and i think she gave it
a long think here
and she decided against it and played
rook to c7 instead of activating her
rook looks very very sensible and then
activated her bishop so again white's
upon her two down but has a nice nice
attack and she'll get one of them back
king d22 a6
and anna was able to
to get out of this bishop takes knight
now exactly what you wanted to play
helping black developer pieces no i
don't uh i don't give a high
uh credence to that when bishop takes c7
that really does that's a very helpful
trade yeah black's having trouble
getting her pieces out right so you
normally speaking you wouldn't make that
ex make that swap you drop back with the
bishop
take a pawn on your next turn and just
hope that your rook on the seventh is is
really good after bishop takes d7 how
did the game proceed
so she got one pawn back got a pawn back
and now blacks up one pawn but black
doesn't really have any issues anymore
and it just has a nice position exactly
so rook takes b7 runs into bishop c6
that doesn't look like a lot of fun no
knight h4 trying to infiltrate somewhere
and the b-pawn is still hanging of
course
back to ca
and this just seems like a lot of fun
for black anna just consolidated her
advantage and better minor piece and the
big difference between anna and irena
crush and then basically fighting for
every us women's championship is
i don't see
crush having so many time trouble issues
and even here where
we both really like black's position
still five minutes left there's always
this issue with her right so sometimes
if it happens every game
sometimes bad things can happen but
probably not here this is just too nice
king f8 a very nice move of avoiding all
the forks right 97 check was a threat
king f7 walked into knight d6
getting out of the pin and it's just
technique black's a pawn up and has a
very nice position exactly and she
basically has to make the time control
anna zatonski that is
ooh h4 walks into oh that's a surprise
move
a couple all right
couple surprising moves here by
both players and this seems quite nice
for black right with the threat of
bishop e8 which would have forced the
trade of a lot of pieces
and it looks like anna is well on her
way
to victory in this game we have another
guest in our studio
making his debut
in this year's
u.s championship is sergey he's with
maurice maurice
thanks yaz with grand master sergey
aaron erin ehrenberg
out of russia born in russia
then moved to israel when you were young
and now in the united states since 2007
i believe correct and now working at
capital one in richmond virginia that's
correct welcome to the show and welcome
to the championship you're a first-timer
here in the u.s championship what has
the experience been like so far i mean
so far it has been disappointing uh of
course in the first game i could have
done better i probably shouldn't have
blundered like five times in the in one
game proved to be
bad
in the second game i actually saved a
very tough position out of the opening i
i got a very bad position this was
against honest shock right an issue yeah
but i think i played well in the middle
game and was able to save this very
tough game and today i thought that i
got a slight advantage out of the
opening but my opponent played really
well and
he was able to
to
to make a draw to neutralize your
advantage sam shanklin that is a very
tough game
what about the conditions what is it
like to play in a championship like this
have you have you seen the kind of
conditions here uh in other places that
you've seen here i mean the conditions
are great it's probably my
from the conditions point of view this
tournament
is best by far
um among those that i have participate
so yeah so far so good i just need to
improv improve my level of playing so
how do you do that in the middle of a
tournament you feel like something's a
little bit off you're trying to play
solidly what do you do to get to that
next level
like you've played three rounds already
what what do you do for round four i
mean other than first game it hasn't
been that terrible uh if i if i made
three draws it wouldn't be that bad like
almost entire everyone in the tournament
makes draws um but yeah i'm just i'll
try to win and
of course it's going to be tough against
kamsky with the black pieces but
maybe i should hold and then try to win
with the white pieces so well you know
komski hasn't won any games either so
it's not that easy so hopefully he'll
give me some chances to
win but you still didn't answer the
question what do you do when you're in
the middle of a tournament to try to
change the tie just i don't i try not to
think about you know
my situation how many points i have or
like how many games left i just you know
play game by game and try to improve
so i i think in the last two games i
played reasonably well i just need to
get
positions that i like
and not to get into time travel and i
believe
i can do i can i can do better we're
sure you can well we wish you the best
of luck in the rest of the tournament
thank you grand master sergei erenberg
in his first u.s championship fighting
his way trying to claw back into the
leaders board
back to you yaz and ben
thank you maurice i was sure you were
about to say jen there for a moment
as we know jennifer shahadi our normal
host yes don't worry
we won't send you to paul mitchell's
has
allergies today hopefully she'll be back
with us tomorrow tomorrow by the way is
a free day for the ladies uh in the
ladies competition mother's day
and but the men will be fighting
in the meanwhile you have on our on your
screen uh also a very important game
uh uh aubry
help me out here
abrahamians
thank you versus katie nemcova
nemkova playing in her first u.s women's
championship as well just like
right
uh we were looking at her game from
yesterday where she gave a draw in a
position we would say
look you just got to keep playing key
play even if you don't see an immediate
win you just have to keep pressure on
your opponent what is happening in this
round well i
i didn't like what tata did in the
opening this is the game where she
played d5 very early on that's right and
we didn't like that blocking her bishop
they got a very double-edged middle game
and then in mutual time trouble
it looks like tatev not only won a pawn
but an important pawn at that
so but now it looks like she's giving
back the pawn to to get it but yeah now
this is really tricky
so i thought it was just i thought
but now i'm not so sure just to see
where we were at so we were at this
point a few moves back okay and how did
the game continue both players in
terrific time trouble right there was a
trade all right then queen c3 eyeballing
this tremendous pressure on all these
pawns right and yeah white's king looks
pretty safe with the bishop on f1 so if
white can start taking some queen side
pawns
she should have a nice advantage okay c6
all right
takes
still you've got to think this is going
to be takes no three great for white no
yeah i thought white was a pawn i
haven't maybe i was just imagining with
that past a pawn that i was really happy
a3 is a strange score for the night but
there was just nowhere else to go all
right
queen d1 threatening 92 check very very
big threat indeed queen c4 check king g7
king h2 breaking the pin
okay otherwise i guess bishop d3 would
have been quite annoying absolutely
bishop e6 trying to move the queen off
of the bishop on f1
queen a6 that was the only square to
defend the bishop yeah tatiaf is just
barely hanging on to her pieces here e4
all right yeah i liked white's game
quite a bit because i thought she was
going to queen the eight pawn but with
the knight on a3 the bishop under
pressure the black knight on f4
i think the idea of e4 was to open up
this diagonal so now sometimes queen d6
is annoying and just put additional
pressure defend d3 knight d3 is a move
sometimes so mutual time trouble this
can go either way absolutely and there's
always that e4 e3 to break open the king
side somewhere as well and let's see if
any moves were made
since this position okay i went back
let's do
let's analyze the game again
just copy
now i'm having my own technical
difficulties
just do a copy copy and then the game
number and you'll be fine
okay
and we have
after the check she went back to a6
all right repeating the position
defending her bishop on f1 exactly queen
d6 they're doing all kinds of discover
checks nasty nasty discoveries c4
finally getting the knight off of the a3
square
wow these are difficult moves to make
and we're at mu 40 for white black still
has to make her 40th move
and we could take the night and then
have many discovered checks for any of
them good right so for example
pardon me bishop c4 queen c4
white's getting ready to rev up the a
pawn and
pawn on e4 is
after a discover check like knight d3
check
white would just drop back with her king
and be perfectly happy
so
i'm not sure that this mcqueen d6 was
well timed by uh it looks scary but
maybe tatev had figured it out and
realized the discover checks weren't so
bad time to get my knight off of a3
definitely so and the queen was doing
great uh job on d1 so i think
a key reversal occurred in that
particular moment
and i'm sure queen d1
to d6 will
get
second guess and with just eight seconds
left on her clock she played bishop
takes c4 wow and now both sides get an
extra 30 minutes wow and uh
this seems like white has withstood the
attack and now the question is how
strong is that a5 pawn pretty strong
pretty strong
and we'll go now to maurice who has some
insights he'd like to share
well
he has lots of excitement on different
boards and first of all let's get to a
decisive game in the game knee versus
melakina this game ended in a victory
for black after a gross
miscalculation well we knew that
white had sacrificed a piece early in
the game but after bishop to g2 knight
to d5 she threw out this move e6
queen takes e6 now look her queen is
under attack it is trapped
the only move is bishop takes d5 to save
it but instead she tried rook takes c6 a
tempo on the black queen and it didn't
matter anyway but overlooked this move
queen to e3 check and after the king
moved then simply knight takes b6 and
there went a queen she kept playing in
the game but it's not going to matter
it's over
after a few more moves a bishop to c3
offering a trade and then just pieces
getting to great squares and then bishop
e1 attacking that king and just ripping
that off and then bishop to f2 and now
it's going to be mate really quickly
when a queen lands on h4 this knight
bismuth move just stopping the king from
running of course those moves are easy
to see once you're up a queen so of
devastating loss for victorian knee
having already lost in fact to the
youngest player in the competition
eswaron
let's go to that game and check that out
because eswaran has her hands full
she is definitely winning this position
of hers right here see if i can get that
up there we go this position of hers
right here is definitely technically
winning she has a couple of options here
let me get our analysis board together
right here
white is in control up upon this past
pawn especially with really strong
chances there are different ways to play
but houdini likes
a5 giving away the pawn saying you can
have it after queen takes a5 then queen
takes d6 creating a new and improved
pass pawn the d-pawn because now that
anchors a queen check here and you can
just push that baby home this is a giant
gigantic way to play the position if she
finds it however after a5 there's a
problem she has to calculate the move
queen takes on d5 and after this move
the move a6
and this calculation is funny she might
be worried about some discovery check
but we saw in the last position with
tatev that not all discoveries are
created equal this move check actually
runs into an easy counter check and now
white is totally winning here because
the queen trade this a pawn is going to
go home so she has to find this move she
doesn't have to in fact a5 is not the
only move it just happens to be an
all-star move and the best move in the
position we'll see if she can find that
because if if she does that'll give her
two points and she'll be only a half a
point behind the leaders it seems that
she's played a different move however
she's played the move queen to h4 also
better for her but not as much as a5 was
a5 was really a serious first class move
but she has definite winning chances
still after this queen move but she's
made our life a little bit more
difficult
we'll see if she can
press home an advantage and it looks
like king e5 has been played and that's
the best move in the position the
veteran trying to hold her own now
against the rookie
es warren up against it to see if she
can win this game and be only a half a
point behind in this year's women's
championships back to you guys thank you
maurice i was just about to say that
that move a5
was not my first move i wasn't thinking
of that and i was actually thinking of
the move that
uh
eswaran played which was queen h4
so
humans are still human humans are still
human and i like her position now
um in the game i want to pull this up
because her please you had uh
this is giving rex a sigh of relief this
is the last player who can take the
sixty four thousand dollars because
or but not in a few minutes that will be
gone because ana zatonski is roping the
point home yeah and the last move
actually was very important it was mu 40
all right i made the time control with a
minute left
and um
well this looks uh tremendous for black
and that's how the game will be over
shortly right a very nice game from anna
you know i've been commentating on the
championship and women's championship
several times over the last few years
absolutely and it seems to me that anna
plays better with black it seems like
when she has nice victories usually with
the black piece just overpowering her
opponents and this seems like a really
good example
yeah
so if anna does win this game as we
suspect then she'll be tied for first
with irena crush and uh well not too
surprising now with alyssa winning her
game which we just discussed against
victoria knee um alyssa well also very
strange only one player in both events
had zero out of two a very close
you would think somebody feel yeah and
alyssa was probably winning yesterday
and won her game today so
you can start oh and two you could start
two and oh but it's it's a race it's a
it's not a sprint it's a marathon
well it's amazing that it goes to show
how truly difficult it is to win all
your games in a national championship
and uh only after three rounds it would
appear no one is going to be eligible
for the bottom yeah
the championship and three rounds of the
women's that's all difficult and it just
makes bobby's feet even more amazing
when you think 11-0 wow wow i still
recall this conversation i had with
anatoly karpov legendary world champion
and i asked him about bobby's result of
winning 20 grand master games in a row
and he said it's just unimaginable like
this was ridiculous
and i asked him
how many grandmasters in a row had he
defeated now this is one of the most
formidable world champions ever
and he said on two occasions he had gone
6-0
on two occasions
and i said i had i had on two occasions
gone seven and now and i told him that
he was part of my seventh
street i had to get that one in but
let's let's uh throw it back at maurice
because he has a very special guest with
him in the studio
thanks as i'm with alyssa malaquina
after a victory must be feeling pretty
good
yeah it does feel good to finally score
a win in this tournament now we saw the
opening play and we saw some unusual
moves she played b3 against your g6 and
after you played bishop g7 she played c3
none of us had ever seen that before
what did you think when you saw that
variation well i've never seen it before
either but
i think i know what happened there she
was probably expecting me to go knight
f6 after a night of three which is what
i usually play and i guess she was
planning some kind of system with d4
there but then after i started with c5
and g6 that threw her off so she started
improvising and after
e5 d4 was no longer possible so she was
just stuck and in the position that she
got that was a big bit of imp
improvisation really creative bit of
improvisation but then the position got
somewhat normalized it didn't seem like
her position was so bad until she got to
this position and sacrificed a piece on
e5 how did you feel when you saw this
move line on the board
i was surprised that she took such a
drastic measure for the last five moves
or so we were playing around her queen
getting trapped after i played bishop
before her queen is out of moves and
knight c8 is always in the air so i
could tell that she was definitely
worried about that and she was trying to
find a way to get her queen out of this
clamp but
there there's just no escape so she
tried to complicate things in time
trouble
indeed and then later she blundered her
queen straight what did she say anything
about the blunder or uh what were her
comments when you played queen e3 check
and suddenly you were taking her queen
well she was surprised to see queen e3
check but i think she knew that even at
up to that point she was already worse
after knight takes e5 i think her she
should have been a bit more calm because
if i play knight c8 in a position like
this she can take on c6 and she'll be
down in exchange
uh let me get that off
whose move is in here it's white to move
it's white so if white plays let's say a
casual move let's just make a random
move
sure move the knight out of um
the threat of the rookie right and if i
play knight c8 then rook takes c6 and
she's down in exchange
but
you know more survivable than giving
away a whole piece to be sure
definitely but we saw in my game
yesterday when things got complicated
even when i was up material i couldn't
convert so i think she was trying to
play more practically here
indeed so you're at one i mean at least
you got off the schnide it's not zero
you're at one who do you play tomorrow
oh tomorrow the women's house
the day off excellent so winning before
the rest day that's right so it's great
to have a win going into the next day uh
but you're still at one what do you do
to to now keep this momentum going
um you know just like i said yesterday
take it one opponent at a time and
around robin we play everyone so
even if i have a bad start doesn't mean
i have to end that way even if i started
with two no doesn't it wouldn't have
meant anything because i would have
still had to play the top players
so now the important thing is that i got
my confidence back and i'm ready to take
on the next games i took what lessons i
could from my first two rounds i noticed
that i was getting better positions but
i could never convert because i was in
time trouble so i just told myself that
okay by move 15 i'm just going to have
like close to an hour on the clock left
because otherwise if you're down time
it's like being down material so that's
what i tried to do this game and i had
enough time to avoid all the landmines
and in this crazy game
good good quote if you're down time it's
like being down material we'll keep that
one hopefully ray robson learns that one
sometime soon elizabeth thanks so much
for joining us okay thank you very much
alyssa milikino what a great quote guys
you've heard that one before if you're
downtime it's like being down material
that's a good one for the kids let's
keep that one in mind going forward back
to you guys just a second i'll write it
down for my new book
i'll take original i'll take authorship
uh we do have a development in round
three
uh one of our co-leaders
alex lenderman
is now the clear leader as he has won
in his game against alejandro ramirez
great opening preparation
led to a huge advantage he had a
material advantage of an exchange he was
making it difficult for himself ben but
he found the right track take us through
the last few moves because maurice was
showing a possibility of setting up a
fortress yeah let's see how he ended up
breaking through here so white had this
very unusual applause structure
all pawns on the white squares but how
does how does black break through
and well maybe
alejandra should have left his pawn on
g3 maybe g4 wasn't so good
but again defending defending defending
the whole game no fun at all
and he got his rook active he got to
break through here oh
so yeah 91 that can't be but yeah maybe
he was i thought he was in some fault
sort of zugzwang or that rig g3 rogue g2
was coming anyway
yeah and this wasn't actually very
difficult for him
because his king got active
the rook gets active everything's active
for black and white he wins the pawn
now he's including it's very easy
attacks another pawn and this is a very
nice finesse at the end he can't go to
the c file because rook check wins the
knight
and otherwise rook d4 is
attacking everything right i was just
thinking king e2 i might have played for
one more trick after rook d4
i would have i would have tried knight
e3
and
i would likely resign after king d8 but
if you play rook takes e4
then bishop b7
and i've got a a night fork to win a
rook
uh ryan win the exchange back so
but okay that was
you know but i play it just
uh to that last moment but obviously um
uh it was gone at that point and alex
was winning he has joined us in our
studio he's uh with maurice our clear
leader of the us championship mr
lenderman
let me just add that he's from brooklyn
uh like i am and and his arena crush
uh so they too are leading the
tournament right now
um although crush has got zatonski on
her heels winning her game about to tie
with her welcome to the show and
congratulations on your victory thank
you so
tell us the truth this had to be home
brew preparation
you played so fast in the opening your
opponent looked dead just from the
beginning of the game
well uh i don't know i thought it was
not so clear i mean up to here was
definitely preparation and i knew about
the move h6 you know i think there are
some other games with where which when
castles or maybe bish takes d4 maybe the
cracking or job of game but i knew about
h6 knight of five uh and the idea is
after castle's knight six h6 could be
very dangerous although that might be
playable as well but i couldn't remember
that so my only option was king f8 and
from what i analyzed uh this was
supposed to be okay but
after this i actually didn't remember it
very well i just vaguely remembered some
ideas really i mean after knight g3 you
played the move h5 you
that was unclear to you what was
happening well i knew uh after knight g3
in particular h5 and ig4 was the idea
but i wasn't 100 sure if i actually
played it in the right move order but uh
it looked to me that i probably did and
i would say so because after ramirez
thought for 40 minutes then obviously i
felt much more comfortable look like
lines working out for me it looks like
it should be roughly equal but of course
it's when you don't know the position
it's quite unpleasant to play indeed
very unpleasant so you
you play pretty quickly even
though you say you were not comfortable
you weren't familiar or you weren't sure
of it were you thinking on his time that
if he played a natural move you would
just bang down your move were you doing
that on purpose yeah naturally of course
i expected knight for knight g4 and g3
it looked like
well if not 94 he's passive so this look
kind of forced when i was already
thinking in advance while he was
thinking for 40 minutes what am i gonna
do here and obviously the other natural
move is b5 but after knight 65 i
couldn't really make that line work so
therefore i already
decided in advance that i should play
bishop a7 because i it didn't really i
didn't really see anything clear-cut for
him that would be uh you know very good
for him so i i played it and i wanted to
see what he does so you were solving all
these moves at the board at some point
like right around now you're actually on
your own yeah yeah at this point i am
yes so we thought you were still deep in
your preparation banging on the moves
when he played the move uh bishop to f4
and then he was the only move e5 and
bishop g5 here we did see you think for
a while so you were trying to figure out
what the best idea i saw that idea and i
saw that idea in advance but it was
still pretty complicated because the
thing is i wanted to play f6 at first
uh
oh okay and i made the best move okay i
wanted to play f6 uh but then after h3
you can show that f6
um
a
sorry i'm using my left hand so
all right let me oh i get what it is
it's this thing all right so there we go
f6
f6 h3
uh f x g